yeah hello and welcome to this video
okay maybe 11 you for more change and we
get an open Sicilian here let's see what
Giovanni Joe to money Joey's coming up
with yeah this is a good line for white
but my problem is I have no no very
concrete idea how it is played oh my god
what is this now 92 I think I'd see to
10 know if it takes a take g7 this is
quite clearly not what black ones okay
the question is do I go every year or do
I play Bishop d3 Bishop d3 looks a
little bit more yeah developing of
course it's better to know what to do
but I'm not in this comfortable
situation after make this up now over
the board so to say yeah okay this is
the possibility of course just opening
up against my as mentioned not so well
developed position I wonder if I can
take and go in five that's the most
that's the most principled choice if I
take by the way Knight takes bishop age
seven King takes Queen d3 check will win
a bond we went upon I can also i can
also play Queen to see five but that
doesn't really do all that much mmm okay
I can take as mentioned and then check
him I wonder if you just moves the king
Quincy five probably clock
let's do it try ok so that was for
naught does this think I mean okay this
is not so easy because he is gotten
reasonably active pieces of course and
its opposite colored bishops where do I
go twin to h5 probably yeah getting near
his King the king is slightly weekend so
this is something to to consider I would
like to get the bishop to c3 I think I'm
trying to get this in those two are
hanging over our unprotected but I don't
think he has a way to exploit it yeah
some bishop something that doesn't work
the bishop gets there this is good news
yeah 94 I guess that looks good ideally
Knight f3 g5 would be would be good he
has night f4 maybe in some cases I have
to be observant that this isn't
something dangerous but in general this
looks like a nice position night here
and i always have quinta g51 maybe just
this song 95 is an idea and night f form
a night air for this 92y I'm stupid I'm
stupid going yeah that's very stupid now
silly very silly now I have to play
Queen to e5 yes 92 went well well that's
really unfortunate okay now i have to
trade queens water that position was a
lot better than having an ending gear
with a ball up man okay I have to do
have two windows ending let's see it's
still pretty okay
yeah night on d3 i wonder if i should
actually trade this now with 95 or not
this is probably not helping my winning
chances if i trade i can go for every
rookie one here this is probably a bit
more testing well well I guess so f3
whoopty one it's a bit better ok let's
kick him away there I'm a little bit
doubtful that this helps them looks you
form see preparing before here maybe
okay if I go on know what it doesn't do
much it's a centralized
mm-hmm so um displaying this one okay
it's there a threat no I can go with you
three hundred that's pushing back night
six maybe night f5 as an idea okay well
this is a self pin right this is a self
pin here where'd you go nitey to this
maybe night f4 yeah maybe this one yeah
night f4 is an additional idea that
looks can just looks good OIC just play
like group t7 now no just no reaction at
all so I can do this well okay it's not
the end of the world he has it protected
now anyway I can take at King f2 and so
on
if I thought Bishop f5 or set an idea
Bishop f5 probably not let's just be
quick shake hear it okay let's cover
this first and then see if we can do
something here can I enter my group to
do six it's probably just plain walk c6
no it doesn't
you
Jim that's not fun for black but I don't
think he should necessarily lose this
I'm sure God f6 if this is a good idea I
would for look at age now rupee eight I
can just hide morning look here's also
not bad I know this now a 6 + f6 now is
under pressure check check it should be
okay that's definitely okay black
resides okay so let's have a look at at
this game and yeah it's really spoiled a
very good position there and then I just
had an ending and I think this is
probably correct 92 yeah that's also
what the engine is giving probably not
the only move but ok cakes cakes this
and maybe f3 I really wasn't sure what
to do him but developing a piece I mean
this cannot be all that bad the computer
gives d5 them yeah well after something
like the five the only the question is
always in something like this I have the
bishop pair in an open position but my
position is not well coordinated maybe
he's okay there that's definitely
possible this is also cannot be that bad
okay the engine gets Bishop g5 as a good
move
okay Jim didn't really think about that
a prioritize kingside development d 595
is also given by the comp okay does this
is this is can this is interesting
there's also hear these ideas to Georgie
for can be interesting this is the
engines line yeah Bishop g5 was probably
a better yeah I know this besides I was
I was thinking about this move but I
thought this is good I can't engine
confirms that I'm a porn up basically
okay client here this is the better
defense where he's upon down but with
opposite colored bishops and blacks good
development it's probably not that bad
so why I hesitated a bit I was really
thinking he could be okay him this is
probably helping me be three years
engines what was something bad about
that no ok so it was also okay yeah and
here here i should be able to to get
much more than what i did but i just not
there for I didn't really see correctly
yeah this is this is just bad but why
does the engine give black an advantage
this looks very weird how can black be
better in this position I don't believe
that okay first of all what about what
is that I should have done probably some
any other movie like this NTM on besides
the porn membership is also quite nice
ok and now what fun how can black be
bettery and that that's crazy night yeah
and then Bishop g4 is giving us better
for black Wow
I mean like okay equal yeah 007 yeah
probably rupee a look-see to me this
this kind of thing Nigel wanna say yes
of course a pretty extreme decision hmm
cannot like this said that rook e8 now k
okay hmm amazing I mean it was clear
that i had screwed something up but I
didn't really see how how bad it is I
mean just you cannot even play for
something in if I have to go night you
one that's sick goo create that is the
engines line wow I cannot even hmm I
could list this you have a tobacco here
I'm not substantially who SMI hmm the
engine thing so amazing him I mean okay
the pawn I mean my extra porn is he
misses age seven but he's just very very
active yeah it was clear that this is a
screw-up but I didn't think it's all
that bad so
huh interesting okay the way it went I
was just pressing for him with no risk
or anything I think I'm I played that
reasonably ok i will be sure to 45 wins
ha I've kind of looked me yet but I
didn't see that ok whoa ok men to gym I
mean I was kind of happy about this
because it is better for wide I can play
for me no risk and I've got more time on
the clock so I didn't really search all
that hard but of course is a completely
winning position about check and play
will be fine hmm ok yeah that was a bit
a bit sad when I did allowed this night
f4 business but it's really amazing how
how big of a turnaround that is if i go
to key one everything's who came I want
to do one thing I want to stress that
this is a good line here against the
current variation c4 I think this is the
main objection towards this opening
nowadays for the black side of course
you still have some good player so
playing it but I think it's quite
comfortable for white I don't really
know the details all that well but last
time I checked white was quite
comfortable ok guys thanks for watching